do you know that gen z is the first
generation in like 100 years
to be to actually tick the other
direction in terms of conservative or
liberal
yeah of course they are that's not a
surprise at all i mean you look at the
kind of wreckage that started with the
baby boomers and
and and has kind of now echoing down
they say i don't want to do that but
that's that's that
it's not it's not ideological so uh the
pew research shows that gen z
is about as progressive as millennials
but
slightly more conservative in some areas
so
when when you'll see these stories it's
funny i think the way pew framed it was
gen z is just as progressive as
millennials or whatever and then you
look and it's like they are they are
they are oh a little bit more
conservative oh a little bit more
conservative
that's interesting i think that's the
framing you should go with that there's
something that happened that's very
different
it used to be every generation was way
more progressive way more progressive
and now it's
stagnant and slightly receding and
i so i remember when i saw this research
and i was like i wonder what's causing
gen z to start rejecting
these ideas there's nothing you want to
know why gen z is slightly more
conservative
in the in the late 90s and early 2000s
several researchers were talking about
birth rates between ideologies and found
that
liberal couples were having 1.7 kids on
average versus conservatives 2.01
which meant that in 20 years you would
have a generation that was slightly more
conservative than the last because
liberals are less likely to have kids
and now more likely to say get an
abortion this resulted in the
gen z being slightly more conservative
simply because there are more of them
i wonder what the correlation though is
on political ideology
between you know parents and children
it's strong enough to make a difference
is what you're what you're
what you're suggesting i think it's
progressive to be a republican right now
well for trump the general idea is to
look at it from a very simple point of
view
that if conservatives have more kids
they'll have kids with more conservative
values
though the kids are pretty woke compared
to millennials like they're pretty
comparable so they're less
they're less conservative than their
parents there's more kids who have
somewhat conservative values
right you know it's a generational
anomaly now we can take a look at
some of the more um i guess the changes
that have been occurring i mean
when i was growing up the democratic
party when talking about pro-life versus
pro-choice
it was safe legal but rare now it's
michelle wolf on netflix going you get
an abortion and you get an abortion
there are the selfie videos have you
seen those whoa no oh yeah there's like
women there's like a trend on social
media
a while back where you know immediately
after having an abortion procedure
people would you know take selfie videos
and celebrate it like it you know like
they just won the olympics or something
it's like
now it's really kind of you know even i
kind of grew up in california i was
pro-choice by default and then
you you kind of watch this stuff and you
say this is
crazy yeah you see lena dunham said she
wished she had an abortion
does she have children can you i can
pull that up for you yeah does she have
children
no i'm pretty sure was her i want to
make sure we get the source oh she
wished she had one
so she could be part of the club she
wished she had had an abortion
she doesn't have any kids okay i think i
wish like could you say that about your
kid
i had a kid but i wish i had aborted no
no she was straight up saying she
whisked at some point
so uh not to get too much into that but
the point i'm making is
we recently had joe biden say that uh
there should be no discrimination if an
eight-year-old chooses to be transgender
there's an interesting thing there and
the way he said chooses because i didn't
realize that was a choice
and there's something interesting about
what is going to be happening to future
generations
and i'm not saying this to disparage
anybody i'm just saying based on a
scientific fact
that there are going to be people who
are having substantially more abortions
there are a wave of millennials who are
getting uh vasectomies or sterilization
you know tube size or whatever
and there are uh millennials like people
that are
they're they're two types before
absolutely just like
i know someone who cauterized her
fallopian tubes or whatever
oh gosh yeah and she's like in her late
20s cauterized
saying irreversible destroy it so
what's going to happen based on that
previous trend like what happened to the
next generation
substantially more conservative dude
i i got it 2016 december 20th lena
dunham
wishes she had an abortion disgusting i
think so
wow celebrating necessary evils is not
the way to go with evil i would say so
yeah that seems fair
yeah it's a social status kind of
a symbol right that's so rare
quote now i can say that i still haven't
had an abortion but i wish i had
what kind of psychotic depravity
is this even if your argument is so so
this is pro-abortion
i always tell people i'm like there's no
the argument right now isn't pro-choice
versus versus pro-life
the pro-choicers are aligning with the
pro-lifers reluctantly because it's
pro-abortion versus pro-life
yeah this was 2016 she said this and you
had that michelle wolf special on
netflix where she's yelling you know you
get an abortion you get an abortion
right
like pro-abortion people are no she
choice no no no no
abortion that's ridiculous it's supposed
to be that way but clearly it's not the
case
i'm not trying to get into this big
pro-life pro you know choice thing i'm
just pointing out
the left has gone insane it's not just
critical race theory
it's something i don't know what dude
but it's going to be pro it's going to
have a profound impact on future
generations
tell me if this makes sense so critical
race theorists would say like you want
people to be a mixed race couple because
it promotes you know
uh
adopted two children from haiti children
that were one of them was severely
disabled
i mean if you're an orphanage in haiti
which is a poorest country in the
western hemisphere
you're in a bad place right and she
adopted them raised them giving them
tons of opportunity
um and the critical race theory kind of
guru of the day who's kind of
ibrahim said you know this
is kind of the mark of a white colonizer
oppressing
black children as kind of this you know
and it's like
you can say and you can say hey look
there's a perfectly reasonable argument
to be made
you know kind of i guess he said
something about taming the savage like
some
totally but it was brutally out of there
yeah yeah and it's like an and
interracial marriage is again kind of
like a bomb
thrown into their narrative because it's
very complex so i i
out of all the dumb stories that around
there i broke a story about
the king county washington library
holding racially segregated training
programs and someone leaked to me these
amazing photos of
signs on two doors opposite doors one
said
uh training for people of color training
for
people who are white yeah you know and
then it's like
interracial couples like you know like
like my kids
my kids are mixed race biracial like
dad where do i go you know am i a person
of color my white person
my wife and i are we going to go in
separate rooms to be trained
to kind of deconstruct ourselves and
learn how to kind of
you know despise each other for these
hidden essences
that are more important than even a a
marriage i think that
there's two things that critical race
theorist drives them crazy
one is interracial marriage and i think
interracial marriage is a sign of
progress frankly
i think it's beautiful i think it's
amazingly consciously
same i mean whoever whoever you love go
for it you know but i i think also
america is going to look very different
in 100 years you're not going to be able
to tell you're black you're white you're
hispanic you're
puerto rican whatever it's going to be
very complex and i think ultimately
that's going to be good i mean
i'm italian my father's an immigrant
from italy oh cool italian people
weren't considered white
right for a long time i think the same
thing will happen it'd be a process of
evolution
as people kind of adapt uh accommodate
um and and
and and intermarry but they don't like
that and they also
really hate asian americans oh yeah the
hatred towards asian americans is
so extreme because asian americans who
are
people of color have the highest rates
of college education
they have the highest incomes they have
the highest test scores
so in a society where that is supposedly
white supremacist
when you look at the income tables by
ethnicity indian americans are at the
very top they have 70
college degrees indian americans
filipinos koreans taiwanese all of these
groups and then
you know white americans are somewhere
in the middle and and and it's like
it destroys the narrative and i call
asian americans the inconvenient
minority
well they because they just can't uh
deal with it right they're
uh they've they've they've tried to find
a way i was in i was in
i was in seattle at the university of
washington there was like a proud boy
event happening a couple years ago
and there was a guy who was arguing with
people i started talking to him
and i explained that you know he started
saying all this critical race theory
stuff
i you know said that's not cool here's
why and then
it's always funny when their opinions
change once they realize like for me
i'm part asian and so what the guy said
to me was amazing
that white supremacists have long
tried to mix with asians that's why they
had world war ii and the japanese were
on the side of the germans
and i started laughing and i was like
are you insane what does that even mean
he tried basically saying that
justification for why
asians are you know bad or whatever
is you look at world war ii and the
germans and then of course
there was this whole period where the
left tried explaining why it was that
there were right-wing people who had
asian wives
and they said it's because you know the
nazis and japan
and the the white supremacists want
demure
you know timid traditional wives or
whatever i mean you said you're korean
like
i know a lot of korean mothers like they
are not demure
they're intense dude yeah they're crazy
like they are
anything but it's like where did this
stereotype come from it's just
ridiculous
it's an attempt to lie to make up this
ridiculous narrative to justify
why it is they're wrong yeah i'll tell
you a cool cool
story that happened and something that i
thought was really inspirational to me
in washington state where i live
um they were trying to basically uh
reinstate a for there was a ban on
on race-based college admissions right
you can't you have to
admit people based on their test scores
and their accomplishments you can't look
at race and
admissions and consequently um and if
you look at the social science data it's
i think highly correlated with the
number of hours per week that they're
studying
asian americans do really well they get
college admissions at the highest
kind of public universities in
washington state they dominate that's
just a fact
it is it is what it is and the
progressives
i guess now a year ago two years ago i
can't quite remember they said we're
going to get rid of that
and we're going to reinstate race-based
admissions
and and again washington state has a
high asian american population these are
people who had never been involved in
politics
you know we come from you know in large
cases these are chinese americans they
said we come
from a place where politics is dangerous
they'll get you killed so we are we're
just here to
focus on our families focus on education
focus on working hard focus on
businesses
and i got involved with these people in
this campaign to to stop this
and and you know what what happened was
really
a remarkable testament to american
democracy these
first generation asian american
immigrants literally
noodle shop owners computer people um
you know kind of uh someone that said
that they were you know transporting
frozen meat i mean
like people who work hard they came
together
they they had some people kind of advise
them they put together a campaign to
collect signatures
to get this thing out of there because
they said hey wait a minute we come from
this country
we come to this country we work hard we
send our kids to college that's how it
works this is the american dream
and these folks are trying to take us
away from it to help minorities
what that doesn't make sense and and
they laughed at them the legislators
literally
mocked them in public wow you you know
noodle shop owners will never put this
thing together hahaha we have power
this is a blue state we're going to
dominate wow the noodle shop owners
they went crazy they organized they
hustled they got donations they got
small donors the corporations all
donated against them
wow the people called them white
supremacists right yeah you know
these asian white supremacists noodle
shop owners and uh
and they won by two points wow that the
first time in
in washington state history that a uh
ethnic minority group
ran a ballot measure and won uh and uh
hats off to him thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you